retired Admiral James sandy Winnefeld
spent four years as President Obama's
vice chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff he's also a former commander of
NORAD which is charged with preventing
air attacks against North America
Admiral Winnefeld is with us this
morning from Washington
good morning Admiral you hear time and
again in diplomatic circles that words
matter particularly on issues of this
high a consequence how do you understand
the president's tweet this morning
well good morning Margaret and Charlie
and Vlad I think that first of all I'm
encouraged that the president is
committed like previous presidents
before him to modernizing our nuclear
arsenal because it is our ultimate
deterrent against any kind of threat
including one from North Korea that
modernization has been going on for
quite some time it will continue and so
I'm encouraged that he's fairly calmly
tweeting out this morning that we remain
committed to that the Secretary of State
Rex Tillerson seemed to be taking a step
back from the radical we heard from the
president yesterday and really
emphasizing again that there is a
diplomatic way out from this do you
believe that the president is directing
his statements at China or at Pyongyang
right now where is the pressure point
well it's a little hard to tell I think
it was a an outburst of sorts I would
counsel being circumspect circumspect in
our rhetoric because after all we are
the great power here not North Korea and
it doesn't do any good to descend into
what you might consider sort of angry
playground rhetoric I think the good
news is that we do have folks like Rex
Tillerson and Jim mattis and Joe Dunford
general Joe Dunford who are the adults
in the room who are staying very calm
here and I think secretary Tillerson is
actively pursuing diplomatic solution to
this problem as best he can and I would
encourage him to continue doing so do
you believe the North Koreans want to
use nuclear weapons against the United
States no I don't Charlie the this is
merely a survival mechanism for them
they are running an impoverished
isolated nation they've seen other
nations who have given up their nuclear
weapons what's happened to them and
they've decided to rely upon this as
their regime survival mechanism not only
externally but internally so therefore
so therefore can we live with North
Korea having nuclear weapons I wouldn't
go so far as saying we can live with
them but I think we really need to just
let them stew in their own juice leave
them alone
they will never use these weapons nor
will they ever give them up as long as
we don't provoke them and as you seem to
be saying they will exactly have them
and we should not stew and get their
juices going but we should lead them
along having their nuclear weapons I
think the key for us charlie is that we
maintain the twin pillars of deterrence
one of those is what we would call deny
objectives and that is to maintain both
regional and national missile defenses
continue to fortify those in that regard
I think there's some more work we can do
to defend Hawaii but we're in pretty
good shape as far as missile defenses go
and the other half of deterrence is
imposing costs and that is continually
reminding North Korea that if they
should be foolish enough to use a
nuclear weapon against our allies or us
that they will bury a very very heavy
concert that mean exactly what we were
saying you believe that we have and you
should know a nuclear defense system
that will work against any attack by
North Korea we just recently Charlie
tested for the very first time our
national ballistic missile defense
system against a true representative
intercontinental ballistic missile
threat like the one that North Korea is
developing and it performed with flying
colors we also have very capable
regional ballistic missile defense
capability in the tha'd missile system
which we've installed in South Korea and
Guam and also the very capable missile
the work code developing with Japan so
yes we are and I believe very good shape
as far as Bullock's ballistic missile
defense systems go nothing's perfect
but they're very good systems and
they're getting better they are and well
you said you don't think North Korea
will use their weapons but they won't
give them up one of the concerns I hear
from US officials is that they could
sell them because they are demonstrating
increased capabilities here isn't
proliferation another threat that we
haven't heard a strategy to counter yet
it is a very big concern and I think
that is why the entire
national community needs to make a very
strong statement to North Korea that not
only will you not use these weapons you
will not proliferate them either or
there will be very serious consequences
and the intelligence community of course
is very focused on that problem not only
the development but also the potential
for proliferation of nuclear capability
of any kind you believe North Korea is
our biggest national security concern or
is it some other country you know
Charlie I've always worried a lot more
about the great powers and in particular
Russia right now we have a very angry
Russia who was expecting to have a very
compliant administration and that has
blown up in their face with heavy
sanctions Vladimir Putin faces a
reelection campaign next spring so I
tend to focus my major attention on that
particular threat more than North Korea
although we have to take the North
Korean threat very seriously to be sure
all right
Admiral Winnefeld thank you very much
sir we appreciate it my pleasure